well another question from Reddit
speaking of aliens uh I would be curious
to hear David's views on conspiracies
and conspiracy theories the extent to
which real conspiracies happen and why
conspiracies that have little evidence
behind them managed to be so compelling
to people regardless also please bring
up aliens and uaps okay where do we
start the conspiracy what uh so what are
in general
as a person who thinks about politics
thinks about this world like where do
conspiracy theories fit in for you I
think there have been conspiracies and
by conspiracies I'm using a colloquial
definition which is basically uh
individuals working together to
um in a clandestine way impact or affect
some kind of event or phenomenon uh very
very broadly I mean certainly that those
things have happened
um the to pick to jump around to some of
the things that were in there I think
the reason that conspiracy theories are
so compelling
is that it's really tough for a lot of
people to accept
there are random events
not predictable specifically at a
stochastic level we might be able to
predict them but specifically
unpredictable
bad events in many ways
I could be the victim of one or you
could or my family could that's really
scary to a lot of people understandably
so and for some people it's less scary
and more soothing in a way to say there
aren't really random events like this
somebody planned it and if we had just
known who planned it it just could have
been stopped because we would have known
exactly when
that's just a psychological level easier
to accept for people and I get that to
some degree because
listen it's it's not the most exciting
thing that everything can just be going
fine and something absolutely horrible
happens and kills who knows some number
of people or so I think that's the the
biggest attractor to a lot of these
conspiracy theories it doesn't apply to
all of them though
but yeah but there's still kind of a
basic understanding of human nature
where people
some people are greedy and want power
and are corrupted by power
so there's a kind of these compelling
narratives that stick
that um
I don't know the vaccine is a is a
opportunity for a powerful billionaire
to implant chips into you so you can
control you further right
it doesn't seem
what do I want to say
it's like for some reason
that doesn't seem as crazy as it should
because you think like maybe Hollywood
contributes to that but you think yeah
you could imagine an evil person a
person that wants more control more
power
and is also at the same time able to
convince themselves as history shows
that they actually have the best
interest of the populace in mind that
they're trying to do good for the world
so they do evil while trying to do good
you can kind of imagine it so it's like
why not
and uh do you listen to people in power
uh authorities they kind of look and
sound Shady
you know like yeah the the transparency
especially the older ones I think
younger folks are better at being like
real and transparent and just like
revealing their flaws and the basic
Humanity but people that are a little
bit older in the positions of power
they're more polished they're more like
they're it feels like they're presenting
a narrative where the truth is hidden in
the shadows so I don't think there's
anything wrong with suspecting
maybe a public figure isn't giving me
the full story yeah totally reasonable
thing to question
um I don't think there's anything wrong
with exploring a lot of these different
things I think the problem becomes and I
know you've talked about this in so many
different ways with other guests the
problem becomes when we lose a shared
understanding of how we would assess
whether any of these things are true and
then both alleged evidence and an
absence of evidence both become
supportive of the conspiracy theory
because if there's bad evidence you
manipulate it and say it's good evidence
if there's no evidence you say the
evidence was obviously hidden by the
people who carried out the thing or
whatever so unless we can have a shared
understanding of how we would determine
what's true these are common
conversations often between atheists and
religious folks how can we deter like is
is my faith in something or my desire
for something to be true a good way to
evaluate whether it is true they're
really similar questions
well let me ask you about Trump on that
front about the election 2020 election
and
maybe the better question is about
January 6th do you think January 6th was
a big deal
I do
how big of a deal compared to what
uh Civil War
I think it was less of a big deal than
the Civil War okay no I mean so you well
it's a very interesting thing though
right because we have not only the the
event that's that's clever actually it's
not only the event but it's what led up
to it and what has happened since and
did it change
what is considered on the table
that citizens can should or might do if
they disagree with the results of an
election so I think that there are
further reaching consequences than just
was the six hour period on January 6th a
bigger smaller deal than the Civil War
and there's so much wrapped up into it
um many conspiracy theories flowed from
January 6th as well uh 60 Minutes
recently featured a guy named Ray Epps
who was targeted by some on the right
um claiming that he was an instigator or
an agent of the FBI or something along
those lines uh there were people
claiming that no real TR was like a no
true Scotsman sort of thing like Trump
supporters wouldn't Riot so by
definition it must have been antifa uh
police let him in or police were you
know all these different things I think
it was a big deal in a lot of ways
because it completely made us have to go
back to the top to say okay what are the
parameters of valid discussion and
activism in the United States but what
aspect of the January 6 was bad for you
well
I mean like if you're thinking from a
big philosophical political perspective
so presumably the number of people hurt
and the number of people who died
is not the only metric to consider here
absolutely I think the sum total of what
it means about how the United States
operates is what's most concerning and
I'll kind of just like flesh it out a
little bit so
summer of 2020. Trump's already saying
they're going to cheat
now the polling
is close but it shows that Biden's in a
good position people aren't happy with
Trump any reasonable person would look
and say it's going to be close but Biden
certainly wouldn't be a crazy thing if
Biden won Trump's already saying they're
going to cheat with mail-in ballots or
they're going to cheat with early voting
or they're going to cheat with machines
or we should do only in person or
whatever else the case may be we have
the election
we knew in certain States how the vote
count was going to go some states stop
counting at 10 pm some states count all
of the mail and stuff up front some
don't everything was completely
predictable
uh at 2 A.M Trump comes out and says I
won
okay but where are you getting that sir
as he claims people always refer to him
where are you getting that and with that
statement immediately we see that there
is a large portion of this country that
either is unable or unwilling to say
wait a second
the polling all said this was a real
possibility
the counting schedules are all being
adhered to
all but Trump won that doesn't make any
sense that doesn't happen it builds
people are donating Millions to Trump
for supposed audits which nobody can
Define and lawsuits which go nowhere and
it builds and builds and builds and we
have a total separation from a factual
reality there's no reason to think by
December 1st right give three weeks to
look through some of the stuff by
December 1st there's no reasonable case
to be made that Trump actually won
but it doesn't end there it goes into
maybe we can just like send different
electors even though Biden won Arizona
Let's just like send I don't remember
how many electors it is in Arizona Let's
just like send Republican electors to
say we vote for Trump but that's that's
not democracy that's not the way the
system works let's make sure we're ready
ready for what exactly and then it
builds to maybe Mike Pence can just like
prevent Biden from being present or
maybe we can just interfere in this
other way and then it gets to let's
break into the capital
it's the height of saying we no longer
comport ourselves attached to what is a
verifiable factual reality
and when we no longer do that we're also
willing to commit crimes property crimes
violent crimes okay different degrees in
order to try to have something other
than democracy it wouldn't be democracy
if any of those things had happened yeah
I I think it's not the height of it I
think
there's still a case to be made that
that did not leave the realm of protest
versus
a violation of the principles of
democracy so to me the height
of what could happen on January 6th is
uh if Donald Trump was much better
executive uh he could take control of
the military if it had succeeded
no not even succeeded the attempt would
have been more
um
empowered
I understand so like
the way not to bring up Hitler every
other word which is something your
subreddit also told me not to do okay
it's kind of an important figure it's
interesting to study that moment in
history because it reveals so much about
human nature and that all of us are
capable of Good and Evil but thank you
dear subredditor or redditor for your
contribution to the conversation I will
keep bringing up Hitler in the Third
Reich and I'll keep bringing up Stalin
there's so much to learn from that
anyway the
enough
um an effective practice authoritarian
could roll the tanks out into the city
streets
to uh establish order
and in so doing pause the process of
democracy
as opposed to a few protesters breaking
in to a questionably uh protected
building I agree that what you're saying
would be worse I don't want to use it to
minimize what the protesters were intent
on doing they failed fortunately oh but
to you the intention was there well the
intention was Trump should remain
president that's the intention and to
what length they would have been willing
to go if by the evening early evening
they you know were sort of like forced
out I don't know I agree with you that
Trump trying to use the military uh
would absolutely be worse you know
there's these reports that he tried to
seize voting machines which is kind of
funny because it's like once you get the
machine at Mar-A-Lago what do you do
with it exactly I don't know there's a
like a comedic element to Trump sitting
around with voting machines but he did
float trying to do some other things I
don't believe there's reporting that he
actually tried to use the military
I wondered to what degree this opened
the door to further things like this
with other uh other candidates on you
know even in the Democratic party also
uh do you think there will be more and
more questioning of the election results
there has been already it's uh very
clearly The Playbook Kerry Lake lost she
ran for governor in Arizona 2022 she
lost what I mean by that is her opponent
received more votes it's like very clear
what it means that she lost she she
insists to this day that she won
to this day she did the same grift Trump
did about donate we've got a case we won
in the case you didn't win they just set
a court date like that's not that's not
what you know lies upon grift upon lies
so they they did it then
um it is I I it's extraordinarily
saddening but it seems like this is now
going to be part of the Playbook do you
think people on the left will start
doing it uh I don't have a reason to
believe that that is going to happen but
I'm not going to say it never could
absolutely it certainly could people on
the left could start using it as a
tactic right now there's not a sign that
that's going to happen but it's
certainly good my expectation is and I'm
not a betting man but I would bet money
if Joe Biden loses in November of 2024
he will say I lost he will call the
winner he will concede and he will leave
the White House in an orderly fashion
you don't think there will be claims of
a hacked election the the ability to
hack elections is becoming uh
more and more effective
with the developments on the artificial
intelligence side the difficulty is
you're basically saying
will something happen without me knowing
anything about the election imagine
there really was evidence of a hacked
election then I would want those claims
to be made but the way elections have
gone in the past I I don't expect that
that's a claim that would be made no